how's it go rest money we're gonna
continue doing all the bowls how I
defeat a letís I had a lot of fun last
episode and I'm really curious to check
them all out starting off with Kano we
go baby
Oh got a hug of love beautiful
Oh shame here we go
catch this [__] Oh riding the throw
what about the other one yes oh nice to
meet you
time for a johnnycake about versus
carriages sorry girl I'm excited to see
this [__] oh my god I'm so excited
[Music]
well worth it
time for air implying that it matters
keeps going let's shoot this [__] it's
a smiley face Lois Lane
here we go sore throat baby how did that
taste I think I think that's the most
realistic one we've seen so far adam ak
okay here we go
oh go back and oh a nice little gift and
we go keep it here we go all right oh oh
everything's going out the new juice
clance everyone oh that's one of the
cool as well as with dal Peng right
drink so pumped up about it
hey let's hug it out bro
[Music]
beautiful [__] beautiful baby girl
this gave me flashback of the Yannick h1
Jesus Christ what like that was a humane
[Music]
hey guy what's up oh nice camera angle
in the end the bone healing
it's okay it was ugly already no big
deal oh of course
how about a double thinks :
ah time for rainin why is it called bug
eyes I don't understand Oh No get out
man
finally crunching this has been great so
far
mind game come here guy have it set oh
she's got two ponytails even now finally
one go in girl that's unfortunate bowels
all the fatalities good times I feel
like I'm a mutant to go her now probably
not
don't try mine that one but if you
enjoyed hit that like button I really
appreciate it thanks for watching with
me and as always stay awesome bros Oh
[Music]